[MUSIC]
I've been in a senior operations role
at my company for a number of years and
I wanted a way to kind of codify
what I've learned on the job.
What is this COO do?
How far off the mark is my capability
are there things I can learn?
So I was really interested being
an operations professional trying to
understand what witness to some
like Stanford is defining COO as.
>> I think what drew me to it
specifically was the bringing a strategic
element to the COO role.
And having that kind of be at
the heart of Silicon Valley.
>> I wanted to work with Stanford
faculty and kind of move beyond all
the readings that I had been doing,
case studies that I had been looking at.
>> I thought it was a perfect opportunity.
For me and us as a company to invest in,
continue to elevate the COO
role within our company.
>> You really do owe it to yourself and
to your staff to put new information
in to be influenced by new thinking.
>> It's important for you to get to
maximize the value of the investment
you're making to take it seriously and
really dive in so you're back in school.
>> It was really important for
me to step outside my context.
And taking something new to be able to
come to the table with new modalities,
new thinking and new approaches.
>> There is a lot of opportunity to learn,
to network, to create relationships,
both with our peers in the classroom
as well as the faculty at Stanford.
>> You're looking for the things
that you can't get out of a book,
that you can't get out of a podcast.
It's the people.
It's the faculty.
It's the connections that you build that
really make this program worthwhile.
[MUSIC]